former gop luminaries speaking out
against president trump should we even
bother with this well tonight here's a
sampler
it's about a person a person decent
enough
stable enough strong enough to get our
economy back on track
donald trump isn't that person joe biden
is joe biden on the other hand has a
plan that will strengthen our economy
for working people and small business
owners
he's a really good man and he's exactly
what this nation needs at this time
is that really the new base of the
democrat party
lobbyists and billionaires but those
so-called republicans were
merely a warm-up act for the most
insufferable of the never trump
genre america is at a crossroads
sometimes elections represent a real
choice and i know that joe biden with
his experience and his wisdom and his
decency
can bring us together to help us find
that better way
they fear joe may turn sharp left and
leave them behind
i don't believe that because i know the
measure of the man
is reasonable faithful respectful
and you know no one pushes joe around
didn't that remind you of the scarecrow
in the wizard of oz like
like this i don't even know where it's
at here to respond is
texas senator ted cruz senator
there's so much to say in so little time
but your response to
john kasich go
well look he he's been in angry denial
for four years i i think what we saw
tonight
was the beginning of the collapse of joe
biden's basement strategy joe biden has
been hiding in his basement
since he won the nomination but tonight
was bernie sanders night tonight
so john kasich is promising voters don't
pay attention to all the craziness on
the democratic side
joe isn't that crazy well you know who
didn't believe john kasich
bernie sanders didn't believe john
kasich because bernie sanders
stood up there and said our radical
socialist
agenda has won we've taken over the
democratic party
and joe biden is ours and and that
really underscores
the stakes of this election if the
democrats win
you are looking at bernie in ascension
you're looking at aoc
you're looking at mark my words
elizabeth warren as treasury secretary
bernie might be secretary of state these
are radicals and that's where the
democratic party is
and i don't think that's where the
american people are ted when um senator
excuse me i've known him for a long time
senator uh the midwest you think of
midwest states
so i just spent last week uh in the
midwest
i'm not getting this strategy i'm just
not getting america's a horrible awful
racist country
we're terrible trump's rotten uh
statues are coming down and we don't
care notice the rioting wasn't mentioned
at all the damage done by the rioting
that was not mentioned
how does this appeal really appeal in
john kasich's iowa
ohio in pennsylvania and in places like
minnesota wisconsin is this
really appeal this stuff
well it doesn't and and the democrats
today are the party of the rich
they're the party of coastal elites
they're the party of manhattan and san
francisco
kamala harris was a bold move to lock
down the vote in san francisco
and and that's who they're trying to
appeal to is is the radical left
when it comes to working men and women
when it comes to union members when it
comes to the ohio
steel worker they were nowhere to be
found they
the democrats don't have a message for
for for teamsters the
the democrats don't have a message for
for
right now antifa mobs are
burning police union halls it used to be
that unions union leaders would stand
together but the democrats have said
we care more about the woke mob than we
do about standing with cops or
firefighters or working men and women
and to go tonight without saying a
meaningful word about the riots about
the police officers being murdered
it's an example of how the democratic
party they're getting
more and more extreme and it's all
because they hate donald trump that
that's what they stand for
is radical leftism and hating trump i
don't think that's a majority vision in
in america
and they go for a hollywood celebrity
to be the emcee tonight uh
of i guess they hope everybody watching
is a desperate housewife
senator cruz that they're just going to
throw in with the democrats hell we're
going to lose the free market
we'll lose police and the suburbs but we
really think this is a fun ride to be on
again
i don't get it i don't think it plays
democrats though also use the knight to
spread
and i have to get your take on this
senator cruz this post office conspiracy
to rig the elect election watch
the u.s postal service
it is central to so much of our lives
veterans
count on the post office to get their
prescriptions social security
beneficiaries count on the post office
to get their
checks he is putting the lives of
nevada's seniors at risk
by trying to defund the post office the
president
may hate the post office but he's still
going to have to send them a change of
address card
come january a note to ms longoria and
friends they stopped sending social
security checks through the mail and
oh 2013 under president obama
senator cruz first it was russia then it
was ukraine
and now it's the post office a new hoax
for
every time and every moment and this one
is
bizarre it is impressive to see the
democratic talking points that when they
decided a message
every single democrat across the country
repeats it word for word
but but you know the post office i'm
willing to bet that not a single person
there speaking
has bought a stamp in the last five
years they have no idea what's going on
with the post office
but look we also know what this is all
about which is the democrats are
desperate to beat donald trump
and so they're pushing for this scheme
that they call universal
mail-in voting because they want
everyone to vote by mail and the reason
they want it
is that mail-in voting is particularly
susceptible to voter fraud they want to
enable
what they've done in california what's
called voter harvesting you know in
texas we have
we have tough rules to protect against
voter fraud in texas and some of the
history of them
they were actually adopted by democratic
legislatures in texas
because there was a long history in
south texas
of voter fraud in democratic primaries
where unscrupulous
uh political operatives for example
they'd go to a nursing home
they'd go to each person and say here
fill out your ballot here and here honey
let me help you
just check joe biden right here fill in
that dot and they collect them all and
then magically
all the joe biden ones get mailed and
you know if if someone was stubborn
enough to vote trump well
they just kind of happen to throw that
ballot in the mail and the democrats
in the trash rather the democrats they
want to be able to enable voter fraud
that's what this whole post office
nonsense is about is because they're
trying to
be in a position to steal the election
it's about their hatred for donald trump
senator cruz really quickly i also
believe
there's a very cynical undercurrent
involved in all of this
that almost wants to see a
building movement toward more civil
unrest
if things don't go their way because
then they'll say oh you took it from the
mailboxes you you stole the mailboxes
you
i i it seems like i find this to be a
very dangerous
tactic they're playing with fire here
with these types of
lies and are you worried about that real
quick well listen you're exactly right
and we've seen whether it's
representative presley or
earlier uh maxine waters who who
urged people to to engage in civil
unrest essentially
encourage the rioters you had in in
minneapolis when when antifa when mobs
were
fire bombing uh stores and and police
cars
you had the attorney general of
minnesota holding up the antifa handbook
and his son the minneapolis city
councilman saying i stand with antifa
the democratic party
when given a choice between
the the safety and security of the men
and women in this country
versus the radical mob they've said we
side with the mob and i got to say i
feel
for the residents of places like seattle
and portland
where the mob has taken over and the
democratic politicians have said
to hell with you to the men and women
that they're responsible to protect
because we're not willing to stand up to
the radicals
who are burning our cities down that's
sadly who the democratic party is
listening to right now
senator thank you so much for joining us
tonight late
on the ingram angle we appreciate it